question-is say we assume that we are in
a simulation we don't try to prove it
anymore it would it be possible to come
up with equations knowing what we know
from the past to predict what inputs
might be from the future assuming that
this is an original idea and it's not an
input from the programmer and we're not
you know on a holodeck with a holodeck
within the holodeck can we you think
that would be possible maybe escape the
simulation David what do you have well I
think you know we're probably stuck for
now with the laws of the actual
simulation of the simulated universe if
it's a perfect simulation we're not
going to be able to do better than that
we're not going to get information about
the character of the simulating universe
now if it's a buggy simulation or if
it's interactive simulation you know if
they're if they're sending messages down
here in the way that God was supposed to
and so and then all bets are off all I
can say is so far I have not seen
evidence that we could use to make
predictions table tomorrow the
simulators are going to you know call
the whole thing off so what we can do
there is speculate as far as I can tell
it's always work turns out maybe we'll
suddenly have a lot more evidence at the
end of the day we are living in this
universe so we are constrained by the
laws of this universe so the the concept
of escaping from this universe doesn't
seem logical to me because we are bound
to be evolving according to the laws of
this universe and not not something
beyond that lots of other universes have
slightly different laws of physics I
don't want to be the first to visit them